[Music]
look at Jessica Simpson thought her
six-year-old daughter Maxwell a greatest
showmen circus themed birthday party
last weekend you could say it's a little
over the big top telling us all about it
as you received a big mommy honor today
in New York I'm being honored for
something that I love doing most in life
and that is being a mother Jessica was
among the slabs getting the outstanding
mother award from the National Mother's
Day committee the fact that people think
I'm doing a pretty good job is the best
compliment pretty sure you've earned the
title last night she again treated her
musical loving kids by taking them to
see frozen on Broadway they loved frozen
of course they knew most the music
as a mother who loves theater it was
really cute to watch them have fun my
daughter's favorite movie is the
greatest show round I mean we've seen it
literally a hundred times at least my
daughter wanted that to be her sixth
birthday party so we had a circus in our
backyard and no pressure but son ace
does turn five at the end of June ace
just wants some parrots in baseball so
we'll see how we put that together now
what is she expecting in return on
Mother's Day Sunday Jessica's family
listen up this Mother's Day I'd love to
just like hang out into a picnic for my
kids to just bring me some breakfast in
bed do a picnic outside that sounds
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]